hey this is presh talwalkar
consider a lottery that involves drawing
five different numbers in order from the
numbers 1 to 60.
your friend gets the ticket 1 19 32 44
53 and remarks
wow
all the numbers are in increasing order
you get the ticket 51 34 16 11 1 and say
interesting mine are all in decreasing
order
another friend got the ticket 60 40 50
32 27 and another got 10 7 21 54 60 but
their numbers were not in either
increasing or decreasing order
you wonder how often it happens
what is the probability a randomly drawn
ticket with five different numbers from
the numbers 1 to 60 has all of its
numbers in increasing or decreasing
order
you can also solve the general problem
what is the probability if the lottery
draws k distinct numbers from the
numbers 1 to n where k is less than n
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
so first let's consider any five
distinct numbers
abcde
how many ways are there to arrange these
numbers
well the first number can have any of
five possible choices
the next number can be any of the four
the one you haven't used
the next number can be any of the three
choices you have not used then the next
number will have two choices and the
last number will be fixed
so there are five factorial or 120 ways
to order these five distinct numbers
out of them how many ways are there to
arrange the numbers
in strictly increasing order
there's only one way
you have to put the smallest number
first then the next smallest then the
next smallest all the way to the largest
number
similarly there's exactly one way that
the numbers can be in decreasing order
it's the opposite of the order in the
increasing case you have to put the
largest first then the next largest then
the next largest and so on until the
smallest number
so for
any five particular numbers
there are two ways to have them in
either increasing or decreasing order
out of a possible 120 ways that you
could order them
so the probability for a given set of
five numbers is 2 out of 120 or 1 out of
60 which is approximately 1.7 percent
now notice this probability applies to
every single set of five numbers
therefore the overall probability for
the lottery will be 1 out of 60 or
approximately 1.7 percent we don't even
need to know the different number of
ways that you could draw the five
numbers we simply know it applies to any
set of five numbers and therefore
this will apply to the entire sample
space
now we can solve the general problem
similarly
for k drawn numbers there are k
factorial possible ways to order the
numbers
of which two are successes there's
exactly one way to place them in
increasing order and one way to place
them in decreasing order
thus the probability is 2 divided by k
factorial we know that applies to a
specific set of k numbers and it'll
apply to any set of k drawn numbers
so the probability in the general case
is 2 divided by k factorial
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description